Speaker 1: All right, folks, the the 2022 midterms
have officially started and I say that because
Donald Trump's rallies are back. Not only does
Donald Trump have a rally scheduled for January
29th in Texas, but this past Saturday, a few days
ago, Donald Trump held his first rally of the
year. It is already in support of 2022 candidates.
We are in the 2022 midterms. This rally was in
Florence, Arizona. It was an extremely dangerous
rally. It was a rally at incredibly corrosive to
democracy based on the things that Donald Trump
was saying. And the entire speech, quite frankly,
sounded like a 2020 election speech. But it's
2022, and when you hear Donald Trump talk about
information will soon come out of Arizona,
you might be saying about which election is.
He's not talking about the election in
2020, even though now it's. Yes, he is.
He's still talking about the 2020 election. And
at this point, if you believe any of this stuff,
you are truly beyond reach now. The election,
the rally rather had all of the normal stuff,
all of the normal Trump lies. Trump's left eye
swollen, almost completely shut. I don't know
that Trump's left eye open during the entire
rally. We still don't know what that's about.
Blacks for Trump strategically placed on the stage
right behind Trump, the crowd getting bored very
quickly until he says the craziest of crazy
things at which point they show signs of life.
And we're going to just look at a few different
moments of this. And to me, the quintessential
moment was Donald Trump, when finally
addressing what happened on January six, 2021,
saying his main complaint is they only talk about
the rioters. They don't talk about how big his
crowd was on that day. Take a look at this crowd.
Speaker 2: They talk about the people that walked
down to the Capitol. They don't talk about the
size of that crowd. I believe it was the largest
crowd I've ever spoken before, and they were there
to protest the election. You were there, right?
Am I right? I think it was the largest crowd I've
ever, and the fake news never talks about it. They
never talk about it. Exactly how many of those?
Speaker 1: It was the largest crowd
at any insurrection incited by a
sitting president ever. And the
media won't tell you that beyond belief.
Guys, I mean, just utterly beyond belief.
Maybe the most notable moment was when
Donald Trump made these incredible claims
that he clearly is getting from right wing
media like Tucker Carlson and other right
wing shows. Donald Trump said white people are
being discriminated against for vaccination
and for COVID treatment. If you're white, you are
put at a disadvantage on getting treatment and on
getting vaccines. That's what Trump said.
Speaker 2: Just denigrating white people to
determine who lives and who dies. If you're white,
you don't get the vaccine or if you're white,
you don't get therapeutics. It's unbelievable
to think this. And nobody wants this.
Black people don't want it. White
people don't want it. Nobody wants it.
It's not even believable. You saw this a week
ago where it came out. Nobody can even believe
it. They don't even talk about it, and they
don't want to talk about it because they know
it doesn't work very well for them. But The
Wall Street Journal described the practice.
Race-Based preferential COVID treatment said
That's what it is. You get it based on race. In
fact, in New York state, if you're white, you have
to go to the back of the line to get medical help.
Think of it, if you're white, you go right to the
back of the line. This race based medicine is not.
Speaker 1: So what's the story with this? Because
people at the rally and on the online right just
accepted it and ran with it. Number one, this is
something that that Tucker Carlson's been saying,
and so have others. Now here are the facts on
this because if people believe this were really
in rough shape, white people, I feel like like
an idiot. Even talking about this, white people
are not being excluded from vaccines. There's a
plentiful supply, and there is no evidence white
people are being sent to the back of the line for
COVID care. As a matter of public health policy,
what Donald Trump and Tucker and others
are referring to is a New York policy that
allows race and ethnicity to be considered when
dispensing oral antiviral treatments, which are
of limited supply because. We know that race and
ethnicity are a risk factor for COVID. OK? The
idea of all of this policy is steer treatment
to people with the most risk of severe disease
from COVID. And as a result of that, we know that
Hispanic folks and black folks, as a result of
historical health and social inequalities are more
at risk of being severely ill or dying from the
virus. It's just a risk factor. That's all it is.
And Tucker, I would say Trump is doing it. Trump
doesn't know what he's doing. He's just repeating
what he heard. People like Tucker and others
are pretending there's not like a sort
of multidimensional risk factor calculus
that's done and saying white people are being
denied treatment and vaccines, which of course,
is not true. It's dangerous sort of fascist,
authoritarian type pabulum, and it's also not
true. Trump then seemingly admits he didn't
win the election. This is just kind of another
one of these funny moments. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We did have tremendous success. Do you
ever hear some of the little the little things
where they analyze elections? If you win
Ohio and Florida, you always when we won Ohio and
Florida, but if you win Ohio and Florida and Iowa
and we won big, all of them, then 100 percent. If
you win a certain number of states having to do
with legislatures and state, we won all of them,
every one of them. There's like 15 of different,
different little tests. And we
won them all. The only thing
we didn't win was the election, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that that's these these
little things are just dropped in where you
say, Oh, so so you are saying you didn't win.
And I'm sure if you call them on and he would say,
Well, no, I mean that they took it from me. Trump
also pushing another Tucker Carlson conspiracy,
which is that the it's essentially boiling down
to the FBI did the the riots. It wasn't really
Trumpists. The FBI organized it and did it all.
Here is Trump talking about that.
Speaker 2: Exactly how many of those present
at the Capitol complex on Jan. six were FBI,
confidential informants, agents or otherwise
working directly or indirectly with an agency of
the United States government? People want to hear
this. How about the one guy? Go in, go in and
get in there. Everybody else get in there. Go,
go, go. Nothing happens to him. What happened with
him? Nothing happens. Did any of these individuals
play any role whatsoever approving or facilitating
the events at the Capitol? That's what we want
to know. And most importantly, why are they
investigating? November 3rd A rigged and stolen
election without getting to the bottom of which
we will never have a fair and free democracy. Why
aren't they looking at that?
Speaker 1:
So again, Trump clearly watching right wing media
picking up any old conspiracy that he hears. We've
already debunked that one extensively. The
other notable thing about this Trump rally
is that Donald Trump was notably more transphobic
than normal Trump. I don't want to say he didn't
do any transphobia during his presidency. He did.
But Trump, really almost relishing the transphobia
here, mentions post-birth abortion as well.
Speaker 2: And we're done taking lectures
on science from a party that tells
us that men are women, women or men
and the babies. This is a fact that babies can
be killed even after birth, right after birth.
Speaker 1: So, of course, the post birth
abortion thing has also been been debunked
at one point. Trump getting that look, you
know how sometimes Trump looks visibly dazed
like that time when Trump said he wanted to
talk about the oranges of the. Remember this?
Speaker 2: Take a look at the
oranges of the investigation.
Speaker 1: Yeah. When Trump said that he
had this visibly confused look on his face,
he had that same look when he, instead of talking
about supply chain issues, he talked about supply
change and looked very confused.
Speaker 2: We never even
heard the term supply change.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess it's sort of a mixture
of climate change and supply chain issues, supply
change. Maybe that's what he meant. OK, then Trump
said. America is not great now. This is a notable
moment because in criticizing Democrats and saying
how bad things are under Democrats, they're not
supposed to straight up say that we're not a good
country. And Trump, you always say America is
the best. America is the best, always. But Trump
actually now saying America is not great right now
Speaker 2: because frankly, whether you like it or
not and some people like America is not great
now, we're a laughingstock all over the world.
Well, you know, I really think the borders
are a horror show, but I really think so.
Speaker 1: That's a notable change in rhetoric,
but overall, a really scary, authoritarian,
fascist delusion of a rally. It's very clear
that these are going to continue. There's one
scheduled for two weeks to the day after this one
on January 29th. The lies are going to continue.
And one of the things that can't be ignored is
that at this point with Trump as the former guy
rather than the current guy, the people that are
going to these rallies are even more delusional
than what we experienced when Trump was president,
and I want to talk about that a little bit next.